um i'm going to be talking about my
shiny app that i created
for the 2021 rstudio shiny contest
and i received an honorable mention
which was really exciting um this was
basically just a side project that i
started
to get a little bit more experience in
shiny and also to explore
a phenomenon that is special to me and
i'll tell you about that in a moment
um so my name is kaya gam and the
title of my presentation is brewing
green tea because the app is called
green tea and you'll see why in a moment
um
okay so just a little bit about my
background i have a bachelor's in
ecology
from yale where i studied tadpoles and
this fall i'm going to be starting a phd
at ucla
also in ecology and evolutionary biology
studying vultures
so i don't really come from a computer
science background
but i learned to use r in order to
analyze ecological data
so i've been using it for about six
years now and
it's pretty much part of my daily
routine at this point but
i don't come from the sort of front-end
web development
user-facing side of things really at all
so shiny was pretty new to me
this year for the past year or so i've
been working with the carey institute
of ecosystem studies as a data manager
and doing a lot of data science
basically every day
and i had a little bit of spare time
this year in between undergrad and grad
school
so i decided to create a shiny app to
explore
synesthesia so for anyone who isn't sure
what this is
synesthesia is a neurological phenomenon
where
well there are many different types of
synesthesia but there's a particular
type called grapheme color synesthesia
and in this case people associate
letters or
numbers or other sort of graphemes like
characters
with colors in their minds and that
doesn't mean
and i have this type of synesthesia that
doesn't mean that i actually see
colors when i see these letters but i
sort of imagine
associations between colors and letters
so i'm showing you a few letters of the
alphabet here
a is very strongly red for me b is blue
c is yellow d is a is also blue but a
very distinct shade of blue from b
so you get the idea um and i have had
synesthesia as long as i can remember
and these associations
have remained constant since i was a kid
and it's just kind of a fun little party
trick it's not it doesn't really affect
my daily life
very much but when i tell my friends
about my synesthesia
they always want to see my alphabet they
always want to know what color their
name is they want me to show them
words typed out the way i imagine them
in my mind's eye
and this is actually not trivially easy
to do because you have to change the
color of every single letter so for a
while i had a google doc going where i
could copy and paste
individual letters to show people what
different words would look like
but that was really clunky and annoying
so
um then i started googling to see if
there was a tool online that would allow
me to show people my synesthesia
and i came across this project by
bernadette sheridan
where she is also a synesthete and she
created a tool where you can type in any
word in this case i've entered my name
and you see what it looks like in her
synesthesia colors
and that's really cool but it's
problematic for me because
this looks really wrong to me these are
the wrong colors
actually several of them happen to line
up with mine but for example
k is not yellow green in my head it's
more of a magenta
so this bothers me and there was no way
to put in my own colors
so i envisioned an app like this where i
would have
one color drop down
selector for every single letter of the
alphabet and every number
and i'd be able to set my own colors and
have other people set theirs
and then type in my name and have it
appear in my colors
so it actually looks right to me or type
in any other word
and so other synesthetes could enter
their own colors as well
so i decided to build it in shiny oops
um
that is where hold on just a minute
i think i'm gonna have to reshare my
screen in order to show you the
app so bear with me just one sec
okay so i built the app um and i called
it green tea because i wanted some sort
of cute little pun
and the letter t is green for me it
initializes with
a bunch of random colors but you can set
them to
my colors so now everything looks very
satisfying to me because all the letters
are the correct colors and you see this
green tea here
or you can set them all to white and you
can pick your own colors if that is what
you want to do if you have synesthesia
yourself or if you just want to create a
palette
you can download the colors as a csv
that downloads their hex codes and their
rgb codes as well
and then you can type anything you want
here um i have it set to type something
i could type my name
you can see there's a slight delay and
i'll talk about that in a minute i could
type hi boston
and it shows up in my colors or it shows
up in whatever colors
you would like to use you can turn the
letters on and off
you can download the rectangles as a png
so those are the
um the images that showed up on my first
slide were just downloaded from my app
and then i also added um some other
features i added an app
where i'm sorry a page where you can
read more about synesthesia
and more about why i developed this app
and i also have a google survey
mimic page here where you can enter your
own information
optionally because i was thinking maybe
i would do some informal analyses of
synaesthetes
and see if i could figure out any
patterns and you can actually submit
your own colors so this listens to
what has been selected on this page and
actually contributes it to me
as a csv along with your survey
responses
so that's just a basic overview of the
app itself but i wanted to talk in
particular about a couple things that
came up while developing this shiny app
that were really fun for me
so i had a little bit of prior
experience developing a shiny app i
actually developed one this year for
work
and it was much more complex than this
app and took me a long time
a lot of sort of focused effort all day
every day
so by comparison this app was kind of a
breeze
i had a prototype mocked up in just a
couple hours
but then i kept going and adding
features
and thinking to myself you know wouldn't
it be cool if it could do this thing
wouldn't it be cool if it could do this
thing
and i was surprised at how much i could
achieve and so just to call attention to
a couple features here that are a little
bit more complicated than they seem
so first let's look at these rectangles
this
although it might not look like it is
actually a gg plot
it looks like just plain rectangles but
it's actually a gg plot with theme
void and geom rect if anyone's familiar
with ggplot
and behind the scenes shinee is
listening to the inputs
the color inputs here and creating a
reactive expression
which is then fed into the gg plot and
it remakes the plot every time
that there's a change to one of these
colors or a change to one of these
letters
so one challenge that i faced with
creating this plot
is anyone who has used shiny before
might know
that the default with shiny is that
reactive expressions all listen to each
other all the time
so whenever one of them updates anything
that is listening to that reactive
expression will automatically update
pretty much instantaneously
and the challenge actually comes in
preventing that from happening
instantaneously or delaying things
so i was having a problem where every
single time
i tried to type text for example if i
typed my name
it would refresh five times so you saw
that just
when i typed that it basically flashed
once it showed you the new
graph with my name but before i fixed
this
every time i typed a letter the k the a
the i the j the a
it would do what you just saw except
much faster and it looked really chaotic
because it was refreshing every single
time there was a change so i had to work
in a delay
where i used the debounce function to
only have shiny listen to that reactive
expression
every fraction of a second so that a
reasonable person could
type something relatively quickly and
not have the refresh happen
on every single letter and i want to
emphasize that this app
absolutely could have existed and could
have been functional without that
feature
but tweaking little things like that to
improve the user experience was part of
what i really enjoyed about the
opportunity to develop this app
another thing that i would um that i
draw your attention to is this toggle
for showing and hiding the letters
and this turned out to be a pretty
simple on off switch where
um this switch is set to either true or
false depending on whether it's clicked
and the reactive expression that
generates the gg plot listens to that
and re-plots the the plot either with or
without a geom text layer
depending on the position of this switch
and this was another feature where i had
sort of dreamed about it
you know wouldn't it be cool maybe some
people prefer it with letters some
people prefer it without letters
and i never thought that it would end up
being this simple to actually execute so
i was really happy to be able to get
this to work
one other portion of the app that i want
to talk about is these color selectors
there are of course 36 of them because
there's 26 for each
letter and then there's 10 for the
digits and 36 is a really interesting
number
because it's few enough that i could
type every single one manually to create
the selectors i could have 36 lines of
code where i create the a
create the b create the c create the d
and that's how i
started the app because i just wanted to
get it mocked up really quickly
i could copy and paste no big deal but
36 is also a large enough number
that doing something 36 times starts to
be annoying after a while
and so this was a great opportunity for
me
to incrementally develop my app to
move toward better practices in shiny
app development so i started with a lot
of repeated lines of code
and gradually gradually i streamlined
everything made it slightly more
efficient until
ultimately i ended up at a structure
where i wrote a function
that would generate each of these color
selectors and then i applied that
function 36 times
feeding in the input ids and the display
text
and the starting colors each time and
that was again really satisfying
and this app once again could have
existed could have been functional
without that sort of behind the scenes
improvement
but it was very satisfying to be able to
sort of streamline all of that so those
are just a few of the features in this
app i could go on i wrote a blog post
highlighting a couple of the
the challenges like that that were sort
of fun to tackle that made the app what
it is today
and um you i'm gonna provide a link to
that blog post if anybody's interested
in seeing my code or interested in
reading about
the other stuff but i wanted to just
take a moment to reflect on some
general lessons that i took away from
this app for developing
shiny apps in general and the first
thing which i've alluded to
during this talk is to start simple and
then build up and really don't be afraid
to
dream about what you'd like to see in
the app and then try to make it happen
this definitely might not be true for
everybody but at least for me
i'm very much a person who learns best
when i have a defined
goal and a problem to solve and then i
have to figure out how to do it
so i did watch some shiny tutorials when
i was first starting out
but i didn't just sit down with a
textbook and try to teach myself shiny
in a vacuum
i taught myself the bare bones i made a
bare bones app
and then i thought to myself you know
what would i like to see
and how can i make it happen with really
no regard to whether the feature i was
trying to develop was
appropriate for beginners or whether it
was you know
something i should be working on just is
it something i want to work on and can i
read enough help docs
and get enough help from from my peers
and whatnot and just figure out how to
make it happen
and that was extremely rewarding and
that's really how i got to have this app
where it is today
and it's a surprisingly successful
process at least for me is to just go
instrumentally like that
and the second tip that i have for
people is
it was very useful for me to debug via
video chat with willing friends or
collaborators
in my case it was people i met on the r
for data science slack channel
so i reached out to a couple people who
were working on their own shiny apps and
had them sort of a stage of development
and we set up uh some video chat calls
where i helped the person
debug their app and then they helped me
debug my app
and it was really um it was really
refreshing and really helpful to be able
to show people in real time what was
going wrong
and to be able to help them in real time
with their problems
and that was um that helped me a lot and
i got some great ideas by talking to
other people
so if you have the opportunity to set up
a collaboration like that i think that
can be a great way to learn shiny
so i'll stop now because i know we don't
have a lot of time but i would welcome
any questions and i will share some more
resources in my slides at the end
thank you
awesome thank you so much kaya i don't
see any questions yet in the chat so
feel free to ask
live as well if anyone has any questions
okay something that i was curious about
is for like the actual
like when you first made this
application did you use some sort of
template or you just started from the
beginning
like shiny app example no i started from
the beginning and it looked really
ugly um i knew i wanted the selectors
sort of in a section um and i
knew that i wanted to get them into some
sort of grid and i think i used some
combination of fluid row fluid page
columns
rows um i think initially i just had
them all in one column and of course it
looked really stupid
and it was really really long but you
know it worked and i guess
i could see that that was functional and
then i gradually tweaked the ui
i figured i'd i it was sort of this
interesting tug of war between not
wanting to focus too much on ui design
from the beginning
but also it's just hard to look at
something that looks really bad
um and i wanted to have everything sort
of
you know uh compact enough that i could
that i could reasonably work on
developing it
yeah cool james i see you had a question
in the chat do you want to ask it
live
uh sure yeah that that i found the
time delay feature you included kind of
interesting
could you expand on that a little bit i
didn't i missed the package you used
yeah um this was a fun one because i
so i've in the past i've written apps
where there's like a submit button or
something where i think the
the reactive inputs respond only when a
button is clicked or something like that
so i was thinking about doing that but i
actually wanted this one to be
more responsive in real time and to have
a little bit less user input
so i was trying and trying to figure
this out
and i had i was talking to somebody on
our for data science about this whole
approach that i had mapped out that
involved
some reactive values and some i don't
even remember what was behind the scenes
and he said oh do you know about the
debounce function and i was like
no i don't know about the debounce
function um so the debounce function
is i'm actually is it a native shiny
function
i'm checking right now yeah so it's just
a
function right in shiny and
it throttles the code in the background
on the server a little bit
and you can specify how much to slow it
down
so in my case i just had a reactive
expression that was the data frame that
was going to get passed
into the gg plot and i just piped that
data frame
into the debounce function and specified
i think it was 25 milliseconds or
something like that
and that just means that instead of
checking
for um updates to the reactive
expression and as fast as shiny possibly
can it will only check
every 25 whatever you know every i
don't know exactly the details but it
checks only every so often um and i just
basically played around with that until
it updated
still fast enough that it seemed like it
was responding to the user input
but slow enough that it wouldn't have to
flash every single time you entered a
letter
um yeah so debounce is the function and
so that was a function of how quickly
someone
was typing the letters in yeah so
because um each
the the object in hand i'll share again
so this text to display right here this
was an input a text input
and so every time this text input
changed
i took that text input i transformed it
into a data frame that then got fed into
the ggplot
and so every time that data frame was
updated
the plot would refresh and so any time
that somebody was typing you know this
is a different entry
this is a different entry etc um
yeah and you can see when i type really
slowly it does update every single time
but it takes just a little while and if
i write something really long
[Music]
it'll show it all at once like this
because i type relatively fast whereas
before it was this horrible chaos of
flashing colors until you finally got to
the end
thank you i see you there was one other
question from robert
klein do you want to ask that one live
as well
or i can read it too um robert asked
earlier can you read from the colors
on their own um not
really because there are a bunch that
are similar i have a lot of greens and
browns
but i can't especially with the numbers
because the numbers are all really
distinct
um there aren't any that are similar at
all and so that's very useful for
memorizing like bank account numbers or
credit card numbers or
you know pins for example i have a
couple pins that
you know i would never remember the
sequence of numbers but it's some
logical it like goes well together and
so i remember it um
so if you really pressed me i could
probably figure stuff out but it would
be a lot harder with the alphabet than
with the
numbers
awesome thank you so much kaya that was
great
and uh if anyone else is is interested
maybe in the future i know
they have the shiny contest every year
and i'll put the blog post where i
learned about kaya's app in the chat too
but thank you so much for the
presentation that was great
thank you for having me if there are any
other questions too
feel free to put them in the chat as
well and maybe put kaia's name on them
and then we could save them for the end
too
but i'd love to turn it over to our
second presenter so we have ralph asher